three two one jay-j
[Music]
time for another adventure you know I've
lived in Los Angeles for three years and
like most people I don't explore the
place I live I go to the same place to
eat and drink all the time but today
it's time to change that I'm going to
use Google search to find a new place to
eat a new place to drink and something
new to do all within one mile where I
currently am Hollywood but first I got
to find you know a stranger to do it
with me some people say stranger danger
I say stranger let's go have a fun time
together we'll go eat we'll go drink
we'll go party let's go let's go excuse
me
do you live around here no you don't
live around here all right no probably
one no no I'm just trying to find at
somebody where the the red line is
people are actually trying to help me
find my way around but I don't actually
need that it was a lie there were so
nice excuse me do you live around here
yeah I have a question are you do you
have any plans for the rest of the day
depends depends I'm shooting a video
right now and I need somebody to shoot
the video with me I'm just gonna take
you out to get some food take you out to
a drink maybe we'll go do something
together if I can call my boss
yeah I'm Jay Jay Keith cool I'm gonna be
here you'll come right back here right
sounds good Jay I would have Jay like
swimming this hot today I could do some
swimming Jay hey hey how's it going back
you got z8 it I didn't know for sure of
course we're gonna go get some lunch
do you like Mexican food I love we're in
Los Angeles I feel like we should get
tacos or something
top work any day of the week let's do
Mexican I love talking food near me
four-stars Lotteria oh he looks a $2 $2
ready we're getting fancy great it's
half a mile from here let's go here we
are
go fatty yeah grill oh sweet look at
that huge pinata no guys are you my name
is Alan I'm gonna be your server today
what is something you think maybe the
two of us haven't hasn't unique well
something that would be the heirloom
tomato and watermelon I'm comes with
some cheese and it also comes with um I
got dressing and here we have okay it's
made with masa so they actually make the
turkey here but it's at the
dark-coloured ready you ready three two
one
Bothwell exactly this makes you want to
eat it fancy style
this is a bomb vegetarian option great
look I didn't mean to order vegetarian
but we did okay I'm gonna just let go
straight down on this one don't say
you're going straight down downtown okay
everybody to what
the cheese and like that sharp turn know
when you're on a roller coaster that
goes like that
and then the heirloom tomato is kind of
like when your mama used to hold you
exactly I would I was no nice to hold
you like nobody can hold your eyes
within the watermelon is getting so
refreshing it's like being front row at
Beyonce concert it's like you know this
it's watermelon vibe it's like a nice
summery treat it is this will go perfect
with the whole Anita's pools in Iowa do
they have air little tomatoes and
watermelon slices yeah I got they do
hope there's only one way to find out
all right put it in the good bye the
other spawns at rooftop Bars in
hollywood i got its critique oh that's a
lot let's go to the most expensive way
you got the W Hotel yeah got a pool
that's on the roof it's half a mile away
I'll call hard in this [ __ ] hard
in this bubble Bao Bao Bao
[Music]
you want to get some fun splash bites
[Music]
[Music]
Jay Jay Jay hmm my dog I am refreshed
yes my dog I am also quite refreshed I'm
getting a little growl in my tummy
probably actually go for this menu you
know I'm saying back to the goon I
couldn't like scroll through the
appetizers you want some steak I'm
feeling some staining I feel like steak
in a pool is the best choice with some
little strips tag okay it might be hi
oh my god oh my god both taste better by
pool I'm just feeling like we end
tonight with a nice refreshing cocktail
at a bar you know and you know in our
let me just do we should do bar nearby
right and keep it simple bar nearby stop
answer cocktail bar the know where bar
not they're like no we're like where is
it with it you know we're four and a
half stars or seven miles away all right
we're headed to the nowhere bar next I'm
cookie oh my god they're warm that's
great I didn't think that meat so and I
actually like get along this low with
great this has been so fun
[Music]
so I want to ask EJ okay
we've hung out this whole day they were
at this bar now but I realized that
through all this I I really don't know
who you are I don't know what you do I
don't know you do for a living I'm a
creative director for our tech startup
we are coming out with an app where
people can get the cards wash without
water that doesn't make any sense Jay
how you watched something without water
hey how's it going good
we've never been here before welcome to
know what about so what's going on
tonight what should we be getting so let
me see we do have a regular menu
however today's Thursday so we also have
martini night going on so we don't spend
martini cocktails going on I never drink
martinis so I'll get a gin martini gin
martini okay and I'll do whatever the
bartender suggests long as it doesn't
have alcohol virtually no to a great day
to an awesome new friendship oh [ __ ] no
seriously shut up or I'll cut on to
Nucky
don't you dare how many think this
[Music]
to a fun nearby adventure to a fun new
bye dear bye there's alcohol in here
there's not that much I'm telling you
it's bitter hey man thanks for joining
me on our little adventure today oh and
thank you for a wonderful evening
afternoon thanks for a whole bomb did
you know about all these fun things in
your own little town no and ever like I
never go out because I just never know
where to go and I never had Google until
today okay we don't need to hit it that
hard I think it's just a matter of
people don't actually get out of their
comfort zone and explore the town and
Google makes it super easy to a phone
nearby adventure thanks for coming along
with me Joshua fun nearby adventure
thanks a lot to do this you're the best
you're the best
you're the mao-a shut up you're the best
I want you another word alright nothing
weird we got to end this video now